[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo el caso de la tenista china
peng shuai sigue dando de qué hablar al
menos fuera del gigante asiático
mientras el resto del mundo presiona por
conocer cuál es el verdadero estado de
la atleta en china el tema está
censurado en medios de comunicación y
por supuesto en las redes sociales que
operan bajo el llamado gran cortafuegos
un sistema que vigila y controla lo que
los ciudadanos dicen y hacen en internet
porque este caso genera tanta polémica
en el país empezamos el pasado 2 de
noviembre la tenista china peng shuai
recurrió a weibo una de las grandes
redes sociales de china y que es
considerada como el equivalente de
twitter para denunciar que un alto ex
funcionario del gobierno la había
obligado a tener relaciones sexuales se
trata de sun gaulu el exviceministro que
sigue siendo un poderoso integrante de
la élite del partido comunista y aunque
la detallada publicación sólo duró unos
minutos y luego fue borrada de la
plataforma junto con la cuenta de peng
shuai pudo sobrevivir a través de
capturas de pantalla usuarios en
internet tradujera el mensaje y lo
publicaron en otras redes sociales lo
que hizo que la noticia se conociera a
nivel mundial
desde entonces la tenista desapareció de
la escena pública y empezaron a surgir
preguntas sobre su paradero
estrellas del tenis como novak djokovic
naomi osaka y serena williams alzaron
sus voces para exigir respuestas a
través de sus redes sociales promovieron
la etiqueta web peng shuai que traduce
donde está pensó una campaña que se hizo
global y a la que se sumaron políticos
organizaciones activistas y periodistas
en su intento por apagar la discusión el
17 de noviembre 15 días después de la
denuncia de peng shuai periodistas de
medios estatales y nos empezaron a
publicar una serie de contenidos entre
ellos este supuesto correo electrónico
que la tenista envió a la asociación
femenina de tenis en respuesta al
comunicado emitido por esta organización
en el que pedía que se investiguen las
acusaciones escuchamos las noticias en
este comunicado incluyendo la acusación
de abuso sexual no son ciertas no estoy
desaparecida ni estoy en peligro solo he
estado descansando en casa y todo está
bien gracias nuevamente por preocuparse
por mí la autenticidad de este correo
fue cuestionada por dos factores primero
porque se retractaba de una denuncia de
abuso sexual contra un personaje
importante dentro de la política china y
segundo porque lo que se supone que es
una captura de pantalla de un correo que
ya está escrito y enviado contiene lo
que parece ser un cursor justo como lo
están viendo en imágenes lo que supone
que se trata de un documento que está
siendo elaborado la situación genera
preguntas sobre dónde se originó este
mensaje
luego periodistas afiliados a medios
estatales también compartieron imágenes
en las que se le ve por primera vez
desde que desapareció de la escena
pública primero estas fotografías donde
peng shuai posa junto a sus peluches en
la que parece ser su casa y al día
siguiente revelaron una serie de vídeos
en los que asiste a un restaurante y
luego a un torneo de tenis en internet
de los usuarios cuestionan que en los
vídeos siempre está sonriente y nunca se
le ve a hablar ahora su preocupación era
si actuaba bajo su propia voluntad
todas estas imágenes fueron compartidas
a través de twitter una red social que
no funciona en china y no es casualidad
ya que no podían publicarse en las redes
sociales del gigante asiático en las que
el caso de peng shuai parece ser un tema
prohibido hicimos el siguiente ejercicio
y esto fue lo que encontramos recurrimos
a baidu el motor de búsqueda más
importante del país
buscamos el nombre de peng shuai pero
entre los resultados sólo aparecen
noticias relacionadas con sus últimos
juegos y victorias algo muy distinto a
lo que sucede en google por ejemplo
donde los resultados relacionados con la
búsqueda tienen que ver con el escándalo
lo mismo ocurre en weibo y hasta en
widget que vendría siendo el equivalente
de whatsapp donde no existe una sola
publicación de ningún usuario en la que
se hable del tema
de acuerdo con la organización
reporteros sin fronteras los medios de
comunicación chinos tanto públicos como
privados están cada vez más controlados
por el partido comunista por eso no es
raro que el caso de peng shuai también
estuviera vedado en diarios y canales de
televisión de china pero la censura se
hizo evidente por ejemplo durante las
distintas transmisiones hechas por cnn
la cadena dejó ver como su señal en
china se iba a barras de colores cada
vez que abordaba la noticia de peng
shuai y como la imagen volvía cuando
pasaban a la siguiente historia otro
ejemplo de como toda discusión sobre el
tema pareció esfumarse del ciberespacio
chino
si una controla estrictamente internet a
través de un sistema al que se le llama
el gran cortafuegos que le permite
monitorear todo lo que se hace o se dice
dentro de sus fronteras y aunque el país
ya había censurado el movimiento michu
que arrojó luz sobre los casos de abusos
sexuales el caso de peng shuai tiene una
particularidad y es que es la primera
vez que toca las altas esferas del
partido comunista que busca sofocar
cualquier crítica en su contra como lo
ha hecho con otros temas como las
protestas en la plaza de tiananmen en
1989 y las denuncias por las violaciones
contra la minoría musulmana uigur en la
región de xinjiang
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
se quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www punto frente 4
punto com
[Música]